women are different and women don't care  if a guy slept with a lot of people but  we just okay like this is kind of a need  to be right and I think on an innate  level you know that it's true because we  just talked to the girls on the couch  just in this conversation the men said  by and large they tended to want virgins  we tended to want men that have slept  with other women and it's just true and  it's not it's not fun like it's not a  fun part of being a woman but it just it  is what it is like the women have  consequences for that stuff men get more  chicks who's lining up to for Drake and  saying oh did he sleep with too many  girls no ingenuously well Brittany  Runner they're running from